et ses invités c'est jordi savall
bonjour on est vraiment ravis de vous
recevoir sur le plateau du 13 heures de
france 2 et avant même de nous dire un
mot vous avez choisi de vous exprimer
avec votre instrument fétiche la viole
de gambe
on vous écoute
et
où
bravo avant c'était super merci beaucoup
petit concert privé pour les
téléspectateurs de france 2 vers si
vraiment c'est un vrai cadeau
c'est incroyable de vous voir avec cet
instrument qu'on a vraiment sentiment
que c'est vous jordi savall qu'il avait
ressuscité cette viole de gambe on
allait complètement oublié j'avais
beaucoup d'autres musiciens qui l'ont
j'ai aussi connaître j'ai eu la chance
de participer à la mise en musique de
tous le matins du monde et ça a permis
prince bien sûr une ouverture beaucoup
plus grande
extraordinaire c'était un des thèmes de
tous les matins devant non ça c'est une
chanson catalane le chant des oiseaux et
nancéens de la castellane
est ce que vous voyez par exemple de
raconter l'histoire de votre instrument
vous savez d'où il vient quelle âge il a
entre qu'elle a souvent été souvent du
xviie siècle est à ce moment qui fait
par un factor anglais barque normes en
1697 et il est souvent une basse de
viole de gambe et j'imagine que vous y
êtes très attaché
ça fait beaucoup d'amis qu'elle
m'accompagne
alors on vous a invité parce que vous
êtes à la cité de la musique pendant une
semaine vous êtes l'un des invités de la
cité de la musique
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de faire
passer parce que vous n'y êtes pas seuls
vous y êtes en famille il ya beaucoup de
concerts tout au long de la semaine
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de faire
passer au public d'écouter on a voulu
faire on a fait sept concerts sous le
thème des contrastes et on a voulu
montrer aussi un petit peu ces
différentes manières d'aborder la
musique de partager la joie de la
musique de récupérer la mémoire de la
musique de l'histoire dans ces cancers
nous avons fait des musiques d'une cité
du nord des musiques d'italie de la mère
des batailles des musiques de l'ancien
espagne du nouveau mauges hier j'ai fait
l'ange marin marais et les diables en
train de se créer deux vieux lit sur
l'époque
samedi nous ferons un dialogue entre des
musiciens d'afghanistan de maroc
d'israël de l'espagne de grèzes des
terrains sous le thème orient occident
alors justement c'est
verdun d'un disque aussi que vous sortez
et on a vraiment l'impression que vous
avez très envie de défendre cette phrase
que la musique adoucit les moeurs et
qu'elle peut rapprocher les peuples
absolument jeu en tant qu'espagnol je
suis bien situé dans la culture de ce
pays où il a vécu pendant beaucoup de
siècle plus de sept siècles dans cette
conjonction de la culture arabe
andalouse juive la culture chrétienne
dont nous avons pensé quand même que
c'était un peu de notre responsabilité
de rétablir un peu de vouloir un peu
montré que ces dialogues entre ces
cultures est toujours possible et qu
avec la musique on peut adoucir aussi
tous ces violences etc fanatisme c'est
ces incompréhensions
parce que la musique demande du respect
pour l'autre dont on peut pas s'entendre
si on n'a pas de respect entre les
personnes qui jouent ensemble bourse en
temps il faut d'abord s'écouter voilà
merci en tout cas vraiment jordi savall
d'être venu sur le plateau du 13 heures
de france 2 donc je rappelle que vous
êtes à la cité de la musique jusqu'au 4
juin c'est bien ça et que vous avez donc
sorti un album entre orient et occident
et pire notre album aussi qui sort sur
les ans je crois sous le métamorphose de
la fois merci luke's minos merci à vous
vraiment certain ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi